This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Our story this week is about a park. Not some massive city park designed by Frederick Law Ooms, that or anything, just an ordinary neighborhood park in a suburb of St. Louis. It's about seven acres with soccer fields, two playgrounds, tennis courts, and a creek that runs along the back. Dave Davis worked there as a groundskeeper in the 90s.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们本周的故事关于一个公园。不是弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德设计的那些宏大的城市公园，而只是圣路易斯郊区的一个普通街区公园。它大约有七英亩，有足球场、两个游乐场、网球场，后面还有一条小溪。戴夫·戴维斯在 90 年代在那里当过园丁。
It was an unpaid position, but it came with a strange perk. The trade-off was, is that you got to live in a house for free, in a good school district, in a nice neighborhood, a park in your backyard. Right at the entrance of the park, there was a house where Dave and his family lived. At the time, he and his wife were struggling to save enough money to buy their own house,
这是一个没有薪水的职位，但带有一个奇怪的福利。代价是，你可以免费住在一所房子里，在一个好的学区，一个不错的社区，公园就在你的后院。就在公园入口处，有一栋房子，戴夫和他的家人就住在那里。当时，他和妻子正艰难地攒钱买自己的房子，
so it was perfect for them. It quite honestly felt like an answer to a prayer because we were newly married, we had two children at this point, and we really wanted to own a home, and we wanted to get ahead. At first glance, the house seemed like just an ordinary ranch home.
所以这对他俩来说太完美了。说实话，这感觉就像是祈祷有了回应，因为我们刚结婚，当时有两个孩子，我们真的很想拥有自己的家，想要生活有所进展。乍一看，这栋房子看起来就像一栋普通的牧场风格住宅。
From the outside, it looked like pretty much any of the other houses in the area, maybe a little bit smaller, but it was when you got inside the house seemed like just an ordinary ranch home. From the outside it looked like pretty much any of the other houses in the area, maybe a little bit smaller, but it was when you got inside the house that you realized, wow, and the only way to describe it is to be quick and say, it's like somebody hurried up and finished it. And that's because that is exactly what had happened. It turns out that Dave's house wasn't supposed to be the home for the groundskeeper. In fact, the park was never supposed to be a park.
从外面看，它看起来和该地区的其他房子差不多，可能稍微小一点，但当你走到房子里面时，才会意识到，哇，唯一能快点形容它的方式就是，感觉就像有人赶工把它盖完了一样。这是因为这正是当时发生的事情。原来，戴夫的房子本来不是给园丁准备的。事实上，这个公园从来没想过要成为一个公园。
It was private property that once belonged to a prominent black doctor. But the land was taken from him, before he could even finish building his home. That's reporter Sophie Kodner. I grew up near this park. I used to walk there after elementary school pretty much every day. It's in the town of Krivkore. It's a French name. Krivkore.
这是曾经属于一位杰出黑人医生的私人物业。但这块土地在他还没来得及盖完房子前就被夺走了。那是记者苏菲·科德纳。我在这个公园附近长 大。我上小学后几乎每天都去那里散步。它在克雷夫科尔镇。这是一个法文名字。克雷夫科尔。
But we pronounce it Krivkore. That's Midwestern French. Today, Krivkore is mostly white, about 75%. And St. Louis, more broadly, is one of the most segregated cities in the United States. That didn't happen by accident. In the past, places like Greed Corps actively prevented non-white people from moving in.
但我们把它发音为 克雷夫科尔。那是中西部法式发音。如今，克雷夫科尔的居民主要是白人，大约占 75%。从更广泛的意义上讲，圣路易斯是美国种族隔离最严重的城市之一。这不是偶然发生的。过去，像克雷夫科尔这样的地方积极阻止非白人搬进来。
This is the story of one of those people. That prominent black doctor, who back in the 1950s, wanted his own piece of the suburban dream. It's about the lengths the town went to to keep him from moving there and a powerful legal tool that was used to uphold segregation.
这就是其中一个人的故事。那位杰出的黑人医生，在 20 世纪 50 年代，想要实现他自己的郊区梦想。这关于该镇为阻止他搬到那里而采取的极端手段，以及用来维护种族隔离的强大法律工具。
I didn't learn about this history growing up. In a white family, I should say, the people of Creve Corps ignored it for decades, led it library beneath the green grass of that neighborhood park. But in recent years, the story has resurfaced, forcing my hometown to finally face its ugly past. forced my hometown to finally face its ugly past. Howard Philip Venable was a renowned ophthalmologist from Detroit. He graduated from medical school with honors in 1940 and became the first African American
我在成长过程中并没有学到这段历史。应该说，在一个白人家庭里，克雷夫科尔的人民忽视了它几十年，让它被埋在那片街区公园的绿草之下。但近年来，这个故事重新浮出水面，迫使我的家乡最终正视其丑陋的过去。迫使我的家乡最终正视其丑陋的过去。霍华德·菲利普·维纳布尔是底特律著名的眼科医生。他于 1940 年以优异成绩从医学院毕业，并成为第一位非裔美国人
to earn an ophthalmology degree from New York University three years later. He passed the board exam with the highest score since its inception. I always knew him as a larger than life character. That is Rosalind Venable Woodhouse, Dr. Venable's niece. Rosalind was close with her uncle growing up. She looked up to him. And she remembers going to the movies to watch her uncle in news clips that they'd play on the big screen. That is what used to play between double features at the movies. And he would be featured because of his accomplishments. Vanneble moved to St. Louis in 1943 during the era of Jim Crow. He worked as an eye doctor at the All Black Home or G Phillips Hospital, which had a reputation for training some of the best
三年后获得纽约大学眼科学位。他以该考试创立以来的最高分通过了董事会考试。我一直把他当成一个传奇人物。那是罗莎琳·维纳布尔·伍德豪斯，维纳布尔博士的侄女。罗莎琳在成长过程中和她叔叔很亲近。她很崇拜他。她还记得去看电影，在他们在大银幕上播放的新闻短片中看到她的叔叔。那是在电影的加映场之间播放的内容。他因为自己的成就而成为焦点。维纳布尔于 1943 年吉姆·克劳时代搬到圣路易斯。他在全黑人的家庭或 G·菲利普斯医院担任眼科医生，该医院以培养全国一些最优秀的护士和医生而闻名。
nurses and doctors in the country. Vanable taught there too. He had this stick where he would start his classes by asking students to spell ophthalmology. That's OPHTH. That's two H's in there. Glacoma and cataracts were a big problem in African-American communities, so Vennable wanted to prepare his residence to work with black patients specifically. One paper that he published on Glacoma in 1952 is still a crucial reference for ophthalmologist today. Vennable was also a Renaissance man.
维纳布尔也在那里教书。他有一个绝招，就是上课时让学生拼写“眼科”（ophthalmology）。就是 OPHTH。里面有两个 H。青光眼和白内障是非裔美国人社区的一大问题，因此维纳布尔希望为他的住院医生做好准备，以便专门为黑人患者工作。他于 1952 年发表的一篇关于青光眼的论文至今仍是眼科医生的重要参考资料。维纳布尔也是个文艺复兴式的人物。
Outside of work, he was a talented trumpet player. He even played with legends like Ethel Waters and Duke Ellington. And music was a big part of the Venable Family life. When Dr. Venable and his brothers got together, they used to do this dance called The Sand. He would spread sand out literally like beat sand on a hardwood floor and the sound of the feet going over the sand was rhythmic. He's always been a kind of dapper in the dressing and he always talked eloquently. You know, and he had like a little funny laugh that he would put on, you know, and he was just a remarkable man, you know.
工作之余，他是一位才华横溢的小号手。他甚至与埃塞尔·沃特斯和杜克·艾灵顿等传奇人物一起演奏过。音乐是维纳布尔家族生活的重要组成部分。当维纳布尔博士和他的兄弟们聚在一起时，他们过去常常跳一种叫做“沙地舞”的舞蹈。他会把沙子撒在硬木地板上，字面意思就像是在敲打沙子，脚踩在沙子上的声音很有节奏感。他穿着打扮总是很时髦，说话总是很雄辩。你知道的，他笑起来有一种滑稽的小腔调，你知道的，他真是一个了不起的人，你知道的。
That's Alan Venable, Dr. Venable's nephew. Alan remembers his uncle as the life of the party. He would talk to anybody. He loved to talk, number one. He just had a presence about himself because he knew he was talking about and he could take over the world. In the 1950s, Venable was a St. Louis socialite. He spent time in elite circles with wealthy black and white people, and he was used to
那是阿兰·维纳布尔，维纳布尔博士的侄子。阿兰记得他的叔叔是派对的灵魂人物。他会和任何人聊天。他喜欢聊天，排在第一位。他自带一种气场，因为他知道自己在谈论什么，他觉得自己可以征服世界。在 20 世纪 50 年代，维纳布尔是圣路易斯的社交名流。他在富有的黑人和白人组成的精英圈子里活动，并且习惯了
being the first black person to step foot in places that had previously been for white people only. And in 1956, he took one of those steps into the St. Louis suburb of Creecore. One day in March of 1956, Dr. Vennebel saw a small ad in a local newspaper promoting 22 vacant lots in Creecore. At the time, Creecore was an all-white community, sparsely populated with plenty of open space. Vannebel purchased two of the lots. He paid up front in cash.
成为第一个踏入以前只有白人才能去的地方的黑人。1956 年，他迈出了进入圣路易斯郊区克雷夫科尔的第一步。1956 年 3 月的一天，维纳布尔博士在当地的一份报纸上看到了一则小广告，推销克雷夫科尔的 22 块空地。当时，克雷夫科尔是一个全白人社区，人口稀少，有大量开阔空间。维纳布尔购买了其中两块地。他用现金全款支付。
By part, I was going back to what we said, I wanted freedom to choose. I wanted to be able to move anywhere that I had money I felt I couldn't move to. That is Dr. Howard Philip Venable himself, speaking on an oral history tape recorded in the 1980s. Just like a white doctor with comparable financial status could move anywhere he wanted. And Venable wanted to move to Creefcore to build his dream home.
部分原因，回到我们之前所说的，我想要选择的自由。我希望能够搬到任何我有钱觉得我本可以搬到的地方。这是维纳布尔博士本人在 20 世纪 80 年代录制的口述历史磁带中的讲话。就像经济状况相当的白人医生可以搬到他想去的任何地方一样。维纳布尔想搬到克雷夫科尔来建造他的梦想家园。
Everybody was excited because it was ranch style. And that was the first time I had ever heard of a ranch style. So that was kind of exotic in my little mind. Venable's niece Rosalind was a teenager at the time. She remembers looking over the blueprints of her uncle's grand domestic vision. Oh yes, he was talking about a swimming pool tennis court, seven nine old golf clubs, all of that. Then some of Venables colleagues at the hospital got interested in the area too.
每个人都很兴奋，因为它是牧场风格的。那是我第一次听说牧场风格。所以在我稚嫩的心灵里，这觉得有点异国情调。维纳布尔的侄女罗莎琳当时还是个十几岁的青少年。她记得翻看她叔叔宏伟的住宅蓝图。哦，是的，他在谈论游泳池、网球场、七九洞高尔夫俱乐部，诸如此类。随后，维纳布尔在医院的一些同事也对该地区产生了兴趣。
Soon, several more black families started making plans to buy lots in Creefcore. But achieving the suburban dream was never going to come easy, even for a group of accomplished doctors with savings and social capital. Right away, some of the White residents in Creefcore started organizing against Vanneble and the other Black families. They were afraid that their property values would decline if the neighborhood became mixed race. So they devised a wholesome looking plan with a sinister twist to keep their new neighbors out. They would build a park on the lots, and they quickly raised $25,000 amongst themselves
很快，更多的黑人家庭开始计划在克雷夫科尔买地。但实现郊区梦想从来都不是一件容易的事，即使对于一群拥有积蓄和社交资本的功成名就的医生来说也是如此。克雷夫科尔的一些白人居民立刻开始反对维纳布尔和其他黑人家庭。他们担心如果社区变成混血种族，他们的房产价值会下降。因此，他们想出了一个外表看似健康却带有险恶转折的计划，把他们的新邻居挡在门外。他们决定在这些地块上修建一个公园，并且迅速在他们自己中间筹集了 25,000 美元来促成此事。维纳布尔博士说，他们成功地吓退了许多其他黑人家庭。所有其他人都把钱撤回了，因为他们害怕。他们害怕了。他们说，如果你不把钱从这里拿出来，你就会失去一切。我去找他们说：“听着，那块地是你们的。即使是那些首付款，就像一辆车一样。如果你对一辆车付了首付款，那辆车就是你的。除非你违约，否则他们不能把它拿走，但他们害怕了。”
to make it happen. Dr. Venable says they successfully intimidated many of the other black families. All the other people took their money out because they scared. They scared. They said, you don't get your money out of here, you lose everything. I went to them and said, look, that lot is yours. Even those downpays, it's like a car. If you make a downpayment on a car, that car is yours. Unless you default on the payments, they can't take out of it, but they got scared.
其他家庭把钱撤了，但维纳布尔决定留下来抗争。他的房产是用现金买的。他拥有完全产权，并不打算放弃。但我是一个斗士，如果我认为我是对的，我会批评黑人、白人、任何人。维纳布尔博士雇了一位建筑师，开始在他的土地上建造一座砖房。但白人居民不断试图把他赶出去。他们当时试图买断我们，我们不卖。然后他们对我们实施了：财产征用。财产征用，也就是美国政府征收私有财产。财产征用的
The other families pulled their money out, but Veneville decided to stay and fight. He had paid cash for his property. He owned it outright, and he wasn't about to give it up. But I was a fighter, and I would criticize Black's White's anybody if I thought I was right. Dr. Veneville hired an architect and started building a brick house right there on his land. But the White residents kept trying to push him out. They tried to buy us out about that time, we wouldn't sell. Then they slapped on us, Aminit Domain. Aminit Domain, let's help the U.S. government takes private property. The rule with
规则是，政府只有在为了公共利益、为了造福公众的事情（如道路、机场和公园）时，才能没收私有土地。但在整个 20 世纪，美国各地的城市都将财产征用作为剥夺黑人土地、维持社区隔离的工具。纽约市的中央公园曾经是一个黑人社区，通过财产征用被改造成了一个公园。布鲁斯海滩，一个由黑人经营的度假村，在20世纪20年代被洛杉矶的一个黑人社区改造成了公园，遭遇了同样的命运。事实上，维纳布尔博士在圣路易斯的第一个家被国家拿去修建高速公路。司法研究所的一项研究发现，在 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代，美国有 100 万人因财产征用而流离失所。其中超过三分之二的人是非裔美国人。这正是克雷夫科尔正在发生的事情。许多白人支持利用财产征用来夺取维纳布尔的土地，
Aminit Domain is that the government can only seize private land if it's for public use, for things that benefit the public, like roads, interports, and parks. But throughout the 20th century, cities across the US used eminent domain as a tool to take land away from black people and keep neighborhoods segregated. Central Park in New York City was a black neighborhood that got converted to a park using eminent domain. Bruce's Beach, a resort run by a black neighborhood that got converted to a park using eminent domain. Bruce's beach, a resort run by a black couple in Los Angeles in the 1920s, suffered the
他当时正在那里积极建造他的房子，并把它变成一个公园。他们以当时的市长约翰·T·伯恩的名字将它命名为伯恩公园，约翰·T·伯恩一直在领导针对维纳布尔的财产征用工作。维纳布尔并不是克雷夫科尔拒之门外的唯一一人。事实证明，该镇还试图修改其分区法，以防止一座名为以色列圣殿的犹太教堂建在离公园不远的路边。犹太人也在同一个公园。
same fate. In fact, Dr. Vanable's first house in St. Louis was taken by the state to make a highway. One study by the Institute for Justice found that in the 1950s and 60s, one million people in the U.S. were displaced through eminent domain. More than two-thirds of those people were African-American. And that is exactly what was happening in Creefcore. Many white people supported an effort to use eminent domain to take Vannebel's land
他们和同一群人有着同样的问题。在漫长的三年里，维纳布尔博士和这座圣殿在法庭上为他们的土地而战。维纳布尔的案子打到了密苏里州上诉法院，而圣殿的案子打到了密苏里州最高法院。所以我们当时同时在法庭上。因此，我们的律师和他们的律师一起工作。这场斗争伴随着这些偏见而来。他们反对他们，因为他们是犹太人。
where he was actively building his house and turn it into a park. They called it Bern Park, after the mayor at the time, John T. Bern, who was leading the imminent domain effort against Venable. And Venable wasn't the only one that Kreef Corps was keeping out. It turns out the town was also trying to change its zoning code to prevent a Jewish temple, called Temple Israel, from being built just down the road from the park. The Jewish people were in the same park.
他们反对我，是因为我是黑人。他们不得不编造这些非常愚蠢的法律来对付我们两个。圣殿赢得了他们的官司。密苏里州最高法院裁定，宗教自由优先于该镇试图强加的分区法。但维纳布尔博士的运气就没那么好了。
They were having problems with the same people. For three long years, Dr. Venable and the temple fought for their land in court. Venable's case went to the Missouri Court of Appeals, and the temple's case went to the Missouri Supreme Court. So we were both in court at the same time. So there are lawyers and our lawyers work together. The fight just came with those visions. They were against them because they were Jewish.
最后，经过漫长而昂贵的法律斗争，法院在 1959 年 12 月站在了克雷夫科尔镇一边。维纳布尔博士因他的土地获得了 31,000 美元，这在今天相当于不到 30,0000 美元。他离开小镇，他的房产成了伯恩公园。如今，该街区的住宅售价远超 100 万美元。但这并不是维纳布尔博士梦想的终结。他把家人搬到了密苏里州的另一个小镇鲍德温。
They were against me because they were Black. And they had to make up these very stupid laws to take care of both of us. The Temple won their case. The Missouri Supreme Court ruled that religious freedom took precedence over the zoning laws the town was trying to impose. But Dr. Vanneble didn't fare so well.
他说那里的邻居接纳了他。维纳布尔继续他成功的医疗生涯，并建造了他一直想要的房子。它甚至还有一个小型推杆高尔夫球场。维纳布尔博士的侄子阿兰说，关于他家人遭遇的故事在当时被广泛报道。我奶奶在密歇根州底特律读到了关于她儿子在圣路易斯发生的事情的报道。所以这是一个众所周知的事实。
In the end, after a long, expensive legal battle, the court sided with the town of Creef Court in December 1959. Dr. Vanneble got $31,000 for his land, which today would be worth a little under $300,000. He left town and his property became Burn Park. Holmes and the neighborhood today go for well over $1 million. But that wasn't the end of Dr. Venable's dream. He moved his family to another town in Missouri called Baldwin.
但在克雷夫科尔，这一切都被秘而不宣。随着时间的推移，这个众所周知的事实变得不为人知。了解这些材料的渠道是存在的，但在我看来，他们并不是真的想知道。但即使没有人谈论公园的历史，也有公开的线索供任何人去发现。维纳布尔的单层砖砌牧场风格房屋在法律诉讼期间已接近完工，它在公园内完好无损地保留了下来。城市把它用作公园看守人的住所。这就是为什么在 20 世纪 90 年代，戴夫·戴维斯会住进维纳布尔博士那半完成的梦想之家里。正如我刚才对你说的，当你看着内部时，你就能看出有些东西是没有完全完工的，比如油漆地板、会议室里廉价的卷筒瓷砖，没有什么能反映出你相信这里曾经是某人家里经过精心装饰的住宅。
He says his neighbors there embraced him. Venable continued his successful medical career, and he built the house he always wanted. It even had a little pitch and putt golf course. Dr. Vennible's nephew, Alan, says the story of what happened to his family was written about widely at the time. My grandmother read it in Detroit, Michigan, right here about her son that was happening in St. Louis. So it was a known fact.
戴夫当时正在当地社区学院攻读副学士学位，他选修了一门民俗学课程以满足毕业要求。他对这个课程项目有一个相当不错的想法。我对这栋房子的所有疑惑，我对座落在这个相对富裕的社区和老旧社区中央的所有这一切的所有疑惑，一个本应是优质房产的地区。这对我来说显得格格入与众不同，我很好奇，所以我决定深入研究，并开始做我的研究。戴夫开始与市政厅和公园部门的人交谈。他问邻居们是否知道关于公园历史的任何事情。
But in Creeve Corps, it was all kept hush hush. And as time passed, that known fact became unknown. The material was there for them to know, but they didn't really want to know the way I looked at it. But even if no one was talking about the history of the park, there were clues out in the open for anyone to see. Vanibles one story brick ranch house which was built to near completion during the legal
他们说不出个所以然，于是戴夫开始翻阅旧报纸档案。就在那时，我开始了解维纳布尔博士，我开始觉得，哇，多么了不起的人。从旧文章中，戴夫了解到维纳布尔是一位充满活力的眼科医生，取得了所有这些成就。然后我开始阅读故事的剩余部分。你知道的，也就是克雷夫科尔市夺走维纳布尔的土地并把它变成公园的那一部分。我曾以为，也许有些天真，如果每个人都知道这个故事，他们会想要纠正这个错误。
battle remained intact on the park grounds. The city used it as a home for the park groundskeeper. Which is how in the 1990s Dave Davis came to live in Dr. Veniples' half-finished dream home. Like I said to you earlier, when you looked at the inside and you could just tell that there was something that was not completely finished about this, linoleum floors, inexpensive roll tile in the meeting room, just nothing that would be reflective of you believing that this was once somebody's intimately decorated home.
戴夫并不知道克雷夫科尔会如何处理这些信息，但他继续记录他的学校项目所发现的内容。他开始和社区里的人谈论这件事。他认为他们应该做点什么来纪念维纳布尔博士，至少应该在公园里立一块牌匾，讲述发生的事情。但随后，事情发生了。家里的电话开始响起。请问是戴夫·戴维斯吗？是的。
Dave was working towards an associate's degree at a local community college and he enrolled in a folklore class to fulfill a requirement. He had a pretty good idea for the class project. All my wondering about this house, all my wondering about all of this in the middle of this relatively affluent neighborhood and an older community, an area where that would be premium real estate. This just seems to stand out to me and I was curious, so I decided to pursue it and I began doing my research. Dave started talking to people at City Hall and in the parks department. He asked his neighbors if they knew anything about the
你是伯恩公园的看守人，对吧？你需要放下公园以及它是如何建立的这个话题。戴夫说他接到了大约五个这样的电话。每次他拿起电话，都会听到电话那头有不同的声音。其中一个，他听不出来是谁。而且每一次通话，声音都变得越来越具有威胁性。我记得的最后一个电话是：如果你喜欢住在克雷夫科尔，想继续住在克雷夫科尔并让你的孩子上好学校，你就把这件事放手，别再管了。
history of the park. They didn't have much to say, so Dave started looking through old newspaper archives. That's when I started learning about Dr. Venable, and I started with, wow, what an amazing guy. From the old articles, Dave learned that Venable was this dynamic eye doctor with all of these accomplishments. And then I started reading the rest of the story. You know, the part where the city of Creekor took Vanibu's land and turned it into a park. I thought and assumed, maybe naively, so if he that, um, wow, if everybody knew the story, they're going to want to make this right.
戴夫不知道是谁打来的电话。他有自己的想法，但无法确定。但戴夫说他开始感到紧张。倒不是怕丢了性命什么的，而是他担心遭到报复。他的家庭才刚刚站稳脚跟，开始攒钱。谈到这我情绪有点激动，所以我要，
Dave didn't know exactly what Kriefkor would do with the information, but he kept documenting what he found for a school project. And he started talking about it to people in the neighborhood. He thought they should do something to honor Dr. Vendible, that at the very least there should be a plaque at the park to tell the story of what happened. But then it happened. And the phone call started at the house. Asking this Dave Davis, yes.
我很害怕，我很害怕。就像我不想失去一切一样。我也很不好意思地向你承认，我放弃了，我不管了。我退了那门课，不再谈论这件事，因为我不想失去我们拥有的东西。抱歉。我想戴夫做了很多人都会做的事。保持沉默要容易得多，让过去的事情留在过去，而挖掘它会
You're the caretaker of Bern Park, yes. You need to let go of this subject of the park and how it came to be. Dave says he got about five of these calls. Each time he'd pick up the phone and hear a different voice on the other end. One, he didn't recognize. And with each call, the voices got more threatening. The last phone call that I remember was, if you like living in Prive Corps and want to continue to live in pre-court and have your children attend a good school district, you'll let this go and drop it.
让现在的人感到不舒服。但当戴夫退了这门课时，维纳布尔博士的故事在克雷夫科尔重新陷入了保密状态。戴夫是伯恩公园的最后一个园丁。这座城市后来把房子拆了。当然，维纳布尔一家从未忘记他们在克雷夫科尔的遭遇。随着时间的推移，这个故事成了家族传说的一部分，尽管罗莎琳·维纳布尔很快就说他们并没有沉浸在过去中。
Dave doesn't know who was calling him. He has his ideas, but there's no way to know for sure. But Dave says he got nervous. Not afraid for his life or anything, but he was worried about retaliation. His family was just getting on their feet and starting to save some money. I get emotional talking about it, so I'm gonna,
嗯，你知道的，这不是我们经历过的唯一不公正待遇。我们是一个黑人家庭。所以这并不是说围绕这件事情的情绪对我们来说是新鲜的。罗莎琳后来拥有了杰出而多样的职业生涯，就像她的叔叔一样。她是美国第一位女性机动车管理局局长。她获得了教育政策博士学位，并担任西雅图城市联盟的总裁兼首席执行官。多年来，她并没有多想克雷夫科尔的事，直到维纳布尔一家接到一个名叫吉姆·辛格的男人的电话。
I was scared, I was scared. It's like I don't wanna lose everything. I'm also embarrassed to admit to you that I dropped it, I let it go. I dropped the class, I stopped talking about it because I didn't wanna lose what we had. Sorry. I think Dave did what a lot of people would do. It's much easier to stay quiet, to keep the past in the past, when unearthing it would
我希望我们能从头开始。嗯，其实有两个故事。一个是维纳布尔博士遭遇的故事。另一个是克雷夫科尔如何从沉睡中醒来的故事。这是吉姆·辛格。他是圣路易斯的劳动法律师，也是克雷夫科尔一家犹太教堂的成员。
make people in the present uncomfortable. But when Dave dropped the class, Dr. Vanennable's story fell back into secrecy in Creve Corps. Dave was the last person to work as the groundskeeper of Bernpark. This city later tore the house down. Of course, the Vennables never forgot what happened to them in Creve Corps. Over time, the story became a piece of family lore, although Rosalind Vennable was quick to say that they weren't dwelling on it.
他说，一个警钟是发生在圣路易斯的事情，也是克雷夫科尔一家犹太教堂的成员。他说，一个警钟是发生在弗格森的事情。2014 年夏天，在距离公园约 10 英里的地方，一名警察枪杀并杀害了迈克尔·布朗。他的死引起了国际社会对“黑人的命也是命”运动的关注，并将圣路易斯的种族隔离历史置于聚光灯下。弗格森事件发生后，克雷夫科尔的一些人开始更仔细地审视他们自己社区中根深蒂固的种族主义遗产。
Well, you know, this isn't the only injustice that we've ever experienced. We are a black family. So it's not like the emotions around this are new to us. Rosalind went on to have a distinguished varied career, much like her uncle. She was the first female chief motor vehicle administrator in the US. She earned a PhD in educational policy, and she was the president and CEO of the Urban League in Seattle. For years, she didn't think much about Creeve Corps until the Vanables got a call from a man named Jim Singer.
我环顾四周，意识到这就是我大约 60 年前和父母一起去过的公园。我开始纳闷，你知道，还有人记得我妈妈告诉我的话吗？她说得对吗？吉姆还是个孩子的时候，隐约从父母那里听说过维纳布尔博士。这一切有一天在他带着孙子去公园时全想起来了。
I was hoping that we could start from the beginning. Well, there's really two stories. There's the story of what happened with Dr. Vanable. And then there's the story of how Creefcorp kind of woke up from its slumber. This is Jim Singer. He's a labor lawyer in St. Louis and a member of a Jewish temple in Creefcorp.
所以我们开始做研究，结果一切都在那儿。当时它被广为宣传，尽管人们后来把它忘了。《邮报》对此进行了报道，非裔美国人媒体也进行了报道。所以克雷夫科尔当时所做的事并不是什么秘密。吉姆开始与密苏里历史学会合作撰写一篇关于公园历史的文章。然后，在 2019 年，他开始发起一项为公园重新命名的运动。他让他的犹太教堂和克雷夫科尔也参与了进来。他们想要剥夺公园的原名“伯恩公园”，并以维纳布尔博士的名字重新命名。他们建立了一个 Facebook 群组“维纳布尔公园联盟”，并邀请居民加入。他们在当地的一个礼堂组织了一场公开活动，对这段历史进行公开讨论。
He says one wake-up call was what happened in St. Louis and a member of a Jewish temple in Creef Corps. He says one wake-up call was what happened in Ferguson. About 10 miles from the park, in the summer of 2014, a police officer shot and killed Michael Brown. His death brought international attention to the Black Lives Matter movement and put St. Louis' history of segregation in the spotlight. After Ferguson, some people in Creef Corps started looking more closely at the legacy of racism in their own neighborhood.
然后，他们联系了维纳布尔家族，包括阿兰和罗莎琳。200人挤满了礼堂。市长通过免提电话接通了罗莎琳。我们必须成为维纳布尔家族的人。是的，我们必须这样。太棒了。房间里充满了兴奋，还有一些紧张。距离维纳布尔博士被逐出克雷夫科尔已经过去了六十年。罗莎琳当时还只是个青少年。她看过她叔叔房子的蓝图，也听过他关于这个社区的所有梦想
I looked around and realized this had been the park that I'd been to with my parents like 60 years earlier. And I just started wondering, you know, does anybody remember what my mom told me? Did she have it right? Jim had a vague memory of hearing about Dr. Vendible from his parents when he was just a kid. And it all came back to him one day
现在，历经多年之后，她即将直接向克雷夫科尔的人民发表讲话。礼堂里的没有人知道她会说些什么。大家好，我是维纳布尔家族的罗莎琳，霍华德·P·维纳布尔博士的侄女。罗莎琳首先感谢了吉姆·辛格和维纳布尔公园联盟的其他成员，然后她切入了正题。从字面意义上看，在法语中，克雷夫科尔的意思是碎心。的确，这曾经是维纳布尔家族心碎的根源，并且在他们后代的生活中一直如此。这是对美国梦的一个基本要素——拥有我们自己家园的权利——的剥夺之源。然后，该家族对克雷夫科尔提出了一些建议。他们希望以维纳布尔博士的名字重新命名该公园，并希望该市建造一座纪念碑，以纪念所有试图融入该社区的黑人。他们还提议该镇设立一个基金或土地银行，为希望在该地区购买或建造房屋的非白人提供市政府拥有的土地或首付款援助。人群听起来非常乐意并支持做
at the park with his grandson. So we started doing research, and it was all right there. It was well publicized at the time, even though people later forgot about it. It was covered by the post, it was covered in the African American press. So it wasn't exactly a secret what Krif Kourt had done at the time. Jim started writing an article about the history of the park with the Missouri
一些能够承认所发生的可怕不公正的事情。公开活动结束后，克雷夫科尔市议会一致投票决定更改公园名称。伯恩公园变成了 H·菲利普·维纳布尔博士纪念公园。维纳布尔公园对我来说是神圣的土地。妮可·格里尔是克雷夫科尔唯一的黑人市议员。
Historical Society. And then in 2019, he started working on a movement to rename the park. He got his Jewish temple and Krif Kourt involved too. They movement to rename the park. He got his Jewish temple and creve corps involved too. They wanted to strip the park of its original name, Burn Park, and rename it after Dr. Venable. They made a Facebook group, the Venable Park Coalition, and invited residents to join. They put together a public event at a local auditorium to have an open discussion of the history.
她很感激名字的改变。她说现在参观公园感觉不一样了。有时候去那里很难，你知道的，因为你会变得很情绪化，但总是会有这样一种想法，你知道的，我在想为什么这是一个公园，因为它甚至不应该是一个公园？对妮可和克雷夫科尔的其他居民来说，仅仅给公园更名是远远不够的。因此，该市在 2020 年成立了一个特别工作组，以弄清楚他们接下来要做什么。克雷夫科尔的市长
And then, they reached out to the Venable family, including Alan and Rosalind. 200 people filled the auditorium. The mayor patched in Rosalind on speakerphone. We have to be the Venables. Yes, we do. Terrific. There was excitement in the room, some nervousness. More than six decades had passed since Dr. Vennable had been pushed out of Creef Corps. Rosalind had been a teenager back then. She had seen the blueprints for her uncle's home and she had heard all about his dreams
他问我是否可以加入这个特别工作组。显然，他们需要在特别工作组中有黑人代表。我愿意为之服务并分享我的意见。理查德·米勒是另一位克雷夫科尔居民。他在维纳布尔公园特别工作组中直言不讳。我从不拐弯抹角。你知道的，我只说实话。
for the neighborhood. Now after all these years, she was about to speak to the people of grief corps directly. No one in the auditorium knew what she would say. Inning everyone, I am the Rathlin of the Benevolence of the House, the Chief of Doctor Howard P. Benevolence. Roslyn started by thanking Jim Singer and the rest of the Venable Park Coalition, and then she got to the heart of the matter. I radically, in French, creeper needs broken hearts. Indeed, it was a source of heartbreak
我说一些别人不敢说的话。例如，里奇不怕说克雷夫科尔市欠了一笔债，而且不是隐喻意义上的债。他们欠的是真金白银。有些人对“赔偿”这个词有意见。如果这是一个问题，那我们就不要叫它赔偿。好吧，我们换个别的叫法。我们叫它诚意金、公平款，或者是让大家重获完整的资金。对赔偿持批评态度的人有时认为，根本无法弄清楚谁欠了多少钱、欠给谁。
to the Venables and continues as such in the lives of their descendants. It was the source of the denial of an essential element of the American dream, the right to own our home. The family then had some recommendations for Creeve Corps. They wanted the park renamed after Dr. Venable and they wanted the city to build a memorial in honor of all the black people who attempted to integrate to the neighborhood. They also proposed that the town establish a fund or land bank to provide city-owned land or down payment assistance to non-white people who want to buy or build homes in the area. The crowd sounded very receptive to and supportive of doing
但克雷夫科尔的案例一目了然，有据可查。维纳布尔家族的财务损失是具体的。你可以计算出来。因此，对里奇来说，重要的是克雷夫科尔通过直接向维纳布尔家族付款，或者资助像该家族推荐的土地银行那样的项目来弥补他们。
something that would acknowledge the terrible injustice that had taken place. After the public event, the Creeve Corps City Council voted unanimously to change the park's name. Burn Park became Dr. H. Philip Venable Memorial Park. Venable Park is sacred ground to me. Nicole Greer is Creeve Corps's only Black City Council member.
我们为警察局找到了资金，1100万美元，我们其实并不需要。好吧？我们通过发布提案做到了这一点。好吧，我们让居民们对此达成了一致。为什么我们不能发布一项提案来筹集资金、纳税人的钱，来补偿维纳布尔家族呢？自美国建国以来，土地就等于经济机会。在这个国家，拥有房产一直是建立代代相传的财富的关键。如今，非裔美国人的房屋拥有率比白人低 30%，而且白人家庭的平均净资产是黑人家庭的 10 倍。
She appreciates the name change. She says visiting the park feels different now. Sometimes it's tough, you know, to go because you get really emotional, but there's always going to be this element of, you know, me thinking about why this is a park, because it's not even supposed to be a park? For Nicole and other people in Creeve Corps, just renaming the park was not gonna cut it. So the city formed a task force in 2020 to figure out what else they were going to do. And the mayor of Creeve Corps
财产征用是原因之一。在克雷夫科尔，维纳布尔一家和其他黑人家庭不仅仅是被恃强凌弱赶出镇子的。他们被剥夺了通过拥有房屋来积累财富的机会。那边都是百万美元的房子。你把这些从他们身上剥夺了。我认为应该以某种方式对他们进行赔偿。2021 年 9 月，罗莎琳和阿兰有机会参观
he asked me if I can sit on the task force. Obviously, they needed a black presence on the task force. And I was willing to serve and share my opinions. Richard Miller is another Krief Corps resident. He keeps it candid on the Venable Park task force. I don't bite my tongue. You know, I just tell the truth.
维纳布尔公园，这是他们第一次来。房子已经不在了，但他们从小就听说过这个地区以及这里发生的事情。终于，他们亲眼看到了。当我看到公园时，我有一种冲动。我几乎，我几乎头晕目眩，因为我没想到它会这么漂亮，亲眼看到它真是一次相当奇妙的体验。
And I say things that some people are afraid to say For example rich is not afraid to say that the city of Creefcore owes a debt and not like a metaphorical debt They owe money Some folks have a problem with that name reparations with that term So if that is an issue then let's not call it reparations Okay, let's call it something else. Let's call it honest money or fair money or money to make folks whole again. Critics of reparations sometimes argue that it's impossible to figure out who owes how
其实当我到达公园时，我几乎想哭，你知道的，因为你看到了所有漂亮的房子，所有漂亮的房子和地块，一切都被维护得井井有条，而这个男人曾挑选过这个地方，你知道的，这让我觉得，如果我喜欢某样东西并且想要某样东西，但他们不爱我，你知道的，他们不想要我，你知道的，对于你爱一样东西而东西却不回报你来说，这是一件可怕的事情。克雷夫科尔的人民到目前为止一直非常愿意支持一种象征性的种族正义——更改公园名称。我认为给公园命名只是一个开始。这只是一个开始。我认为给公园命名只是一个开始。这只是一个起点。
much and to whom. But the Creevecore case is clear cut and well documented. The financial losses to the Venable family are concrete. You can calculate them. And so for Rich, it's important that Creevecore make it up to the Venable family by paying them directly or by funding something like the land bank that the family recommended.
目前，该市正在为公园内的纪念碑做计划，类似于赔偿的措施仍然有可能发生。因为尽管象征性的姿态很好，但阿兰·维纳布尔希望克雷夫科尔的人民记住他叔叔的这一点。他不想当公园。甚至不是一个以他的名字命名的美丽的大公园。他不想去公园。他想在那里建造自己的家，并抚养一个家庭。
We found money for a police station $11 million that we really didn't need. Okay? And we did that by issuing a proposition. Okay, and we got the residents to agree on it. Why can't we issue a proposition to raise money, taxpayers dollars, to make the venerable family home? Since the founding of the United States, land has equaled economic opportunity. In this country, owning property has been key to building wealth that lasts, from one generation to the next. Today, home ownership for black Americans is 30% lower than for white Americans, and white families have a net worth that is 10 times higher on average than that of black families.
接下来，将更多地介绍全国各地如何利用财产征用剥夺黑人房主的土地，以及夺回部分土地的新运动。广告之后见。欢迎回来，我是苏菲·科德纳，她给我们带来了关于财产征用那篇报道。你知道这个故事，因为这是发生在你的家乡的一个特定事件。但财产征用的整个概念，你知道的，从人们手中夺取土地，确实是一个全国性的问题。是的，所以这发生在我所在的克雷夫科尔，但它也发生在全国各地。
Eminent domain is part of the reason why. In Creefcourt, the Vaniboles and the other black families weren't just bullied out of town. They were bullied out of the opportunity to grow wealth there by owning a home. Those are million dollar houses over there. You took that away from them. And I think he should be compensated for it, you know, one way or another. In September of 2021, Rosland and Alan got a chance to visit
财产征用是二战后 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代城市更新工作的重要组成部分。全国各地的城市将获得联邦政府的资助，基本上是推倒某些社区。他们称其为荒废或某种标准。他们这样做是为了腾出空间进行新的开发。它经常成为低收入社区和有色人种社区的目标。
Venable Park for the first time. The house is no longer there, but they have been hearing about this area and what happened here since childhood. Finally, they saw it with their own eyes. When I saw the park, I got a rush. I was almost, I was almost dizzy because I had no idea that it was so beautiful and it was quite an experience to actually see it for the first time.
除了城市更新，财产征用也被用来针对特定人群。这就是维纳布尔博士案发生的情况，对吧？是的，完全正确。这通常与维持区域隔离或为了资源而夺取特别有价值的土地有关。
Actually when I arrived at the park, I almost made you want to cry, you know, because you saw all the beautiful homes, all the beautiful homes and lots and everything was all kept up together And this man had picked this area out, you know, and it made me think like if I love something and I want something But they don't love me, you know, they don't want me, you know, and that's a terrible thing for you to love something and something don't love you back. The people of Creef Corps have so far been more than willing to support a symbolic kind of racial justice, a name change. I think naming the park is just a start. It's just a starting change. I think naming the park is just a start. It's just a starting point.
所以，全国各地有很多这样的故事。在报道的过程中，我了解到了这个组织。我认为非常有趣，叫做“我的土地在哪里？”。他们实际上正专注于这个确切的问题，即收回从黑人手中偷走的土地。我与肖蒂恩·马丁谈过此事。
Right now, the city is making plans for a memorial at the park and it's still possible that something more like reparations could happen to. Because as nice as symbolic gestures are, Alan Vanneble wants the people of Creve Corps to remember this about his uncle. He didn't want to part. Not even a big beautiful park with his name on it. He didn't want to part now. He wanted to build his home and raise a family there.
她是创始人之一。我们成立于 2021 年，我们的使命是帮助美国的黑人家庭收回被盗土地并确保获得赔偿。所以 2021 年真的很近。那么他们是如何开始的呢？是的，该组织诞生于南加州去年达到高潮的一起事件。那是一个名为布鲁斯海滩的地方，这是一个由黑人夫妇拥有的热门度假村。他们的名字叫威拉和查尔斯·布鲁斯。在 20 世纪 20 年代，曼哈顿海滩市利用财产征用夺取了这块土地。这座城市说他们想要它来建一个公园。
Coming up, more on how eminent domain was used across the country to strip black homeowners of their land and a new movement to get some of it back. After this. So I'm back with Sophie Codner, who brought us that piece about eminent domain. And you know about this story because this was a particular incident that happened in your hometown. But this whole concept of eminent domain, you know, taking land from people is really a national issue. Yeah, so this happened in Creefcore where I'm from, but it also happened all over the
是的。我的意思是，这听起来和维纳布尔的故事一模一样。没错。所以香蒂的联合创始人，她的名字叫卡万·沃德。她当时住在曼哈顿海滩，听说了这段历史。在乔治·弗洛伊德被杀后，她决定于 2020 年 6 月 10 日在布鲁斯海滩公园举办一场活动，向社区宣传布鲁斯一家的遭遇。一些布鲁斯家族的成员最终参加了野餐，就在那时，卡万决定应该有一种方法，
country. Eminent domain was a big part of the urban renewal efforts that happened after World War 2 in the 1950s and 60s. Cities across the country would get funding from the federal government to basically bulldoze certain neighborhoods. They'd call them blighted or some standard. And they'd do that to make space for newer development. And it was often used to target low-income neighborhoods
某种政策机制，真正将公园的土地归还给布鲁斯家族。她进行了一些社区组织、倡导工作。肯定有很多阻力，但在 2021 年秋天，它实现了。人们认为这是美国历史上第一次将从黑人手中偷走的土地真正归还给他们的后代。
and neighborhoods of color. And outside of urban renewal, eminent domain was used to target specific people, too. And this is what happened in the case with Dr. Van Atwell, right? Yeah, exactly. It often had to do with keeping area segregated or taking particularly valuable land, specifically for its resources.
哇。布鲁斯海滩和卡万的工作表明，事情是可以有所作为的。如果我们能找到证据证明，你知道的，一个家庭或个人拥有土地，而土地是通过各种手段被剥夺的。特别是如果这些手段带有种族动机，那么我们就必须为此做点什么。香蒂告诉我，她想和卡万一起创立“我的土地在哪里？”的部分原因，实际上来自于阅读更多关于乔治·弗洛伊德家族历史的内容。
So again, there are a lot of stories like this all around the country. And while I was reporting, I learned about this organization. I thought was really interesting called, where is my land? And they're actually focused on this exact issue, reclaiming land stolen from black people. I talked with a Shawntine Martin about it.
她在《华盛顿报》的一篇报道中读到了它。然后，该报道中真正让我留有印象、铭刻在心的部分之一是，他的曾曾祖父曼宁·希拉里·托马斯·斯图尔特二世曾在北卡罗来纳州获得了几百英亩的土地。正如乔治·弗洛伊德的家人向《华盛顿报》讲述的那样，这块土地被白人农民侵占了。因此，这段历史与现实直接相连，变得非常突出且真切。
She's one of the founders. We were established in 2021 and our mission is to help Black families in America reclaim stolen land and secure restitution. So 2021 is really recent. So what how do they get started? Yeah, the organization was born out of this incident in Southern California that came to a head last year. It was this place called Bruce's Beach, which was a popular resort owned by a black couple. Their names were Willa and Charles Bruce. And in the 1920s, the city of Manhattan Beach used eminent domain to take the land. And the city said they wanted it for a park.
她是创始人之一。我们成立于2021年，我们的使命是帮助美洲的黑人家庭夺回被盗土地并确保获得赔偿。所以2021年真的是最近的事。那么，他们是如何开始的呢？是的，该组织诞生于去年在南加州发生的这一事件。这是一个叫做布鲁斯海滩的地方，这是一个黑人夫妇拥有的热门度假胜地。他们的名字叫威拉和查尔斯·布鲁斯。在20世纪20年代，曼哈顿海滩市利用征收权夺取了这块土地。该市表示他们希望将其用于公园。
Yeah. I mean, that sounds exactly like the Venomple story. Right. So Ashanti's co-founder, her name's Kavan Ward. She was living in Manhattan Beach when she heard about this history. And after George Floyd was killed, she decided to hold an event at Bruce's Beach Park on June 10th and 2020 to get the word out to the community about what had happened to the Bruce's. Some of the Bruce family ended up attending the picnic, and that's when Kovan decided there should really be a way,
是的。我的意思是，这听起来完全像是维诺姆普尔的故事。对吧。所以阿香蒂的联合创始人，她的名字叫卡万·沃德。当她听到这段历史时，她正住在曼哈顿海滩。乔治·弗洛伊德被杀后，她决定于2020年6月19日在布鲁斯海滩公园举办一场活动，向社区宣传布鲁斯一家遭遇的事情。布鲁斯家族的一些成员最终参加了野餐，正是在那时，科万决定确实应该有一种方法，
some policy mechanism to actually return the land of the park to the Bruce family. She lied some community organizing, advocacy work. There was definitely a lot of pushback, but in the fall of 2021, it happened. And it's thought to be the first time in the history of the United States that land stolen from black people was actually returned to their descendants.
某种政策机制，将公园的土地真正归还给布鲁斯家族。她进行了一些社区组织和倡导工作。肯定有很多阻力，但在2021年秋天，它实现了。人们认为这是美国历史上第一次将从黑人那里偷来的土地真正归还给他们的后代。
Wow. Bruce's beach and Kovans' work showed that something can be done. If we can find evidence that, you know, a family or an individual owned land, and it was taken from them by various means. And particularly if those means were racially motivated, then we have to do something about that. Ashanti told me that part of the reason she wanted to start, where is my land with Kavan? Actually came from reading more about George Floyd's
哇。布鲁斯海滩和科万的工作表明，有些事情是可以做的。如果我们能找到证据，你知道的，一个家庭或个人拥有土地，而这块土地是通过各种手段被夺走的。特别是如果这些手段带有种族动机，那么我们就必须对此采取行动。阿香蒂告诉我，她想和卡万一起创办“我的土地在哪里”的部分原因。实际上来自于阅读更多关于乔治·弗洛伊德的事。
family history. She read about it in a story in the Washington Post. Then one of the parts of that story that just really stayed with me and stuck with me is that his great-great-grandfather, Manning Hillary Thomas Stewart Jr., he had acquired a few hundred acres of land in North Carolina. And as told to the Washington Post by George Floyd's family, that land was seized by white farmers. So it just becomes very salient and palpable that this history is directly connected to
家族历史。她在《华盛顿邮报》的一篇报道中读到了它。然后，该报道中真正留在我的记忆中并深深触动我的一部分是，他的曾曾祖父曼宁·希拉里·托马斯·斯图尔特二世，在北卡罗来纳州获得了几百英亩的土地。正如乔治·弗洛伊德的家人向《华盛顿邮报》讲述的那样，这片土地被白人农民侵占了。因此，这段历史与以下内容的直接联系变得非常突出和显而易见：
some of the issues that we're facing now. I mean, it's such an important point because, you know, first, we knew such a narrow slice of the end of George Floyd's life like literally like on tape And then you get to know him as a person his whole life and to think about like The whole history of his family and how it all led to this moment is really powerful stuff Right, it's like you know thinking about Cards being stacked against someone and that's that's sort of the that's what systematic racism is. Yeah, yeah.
我们现在正面临的一些问题。我的意思是，这是一个非常重要的点，因为，你知道的，首先，我们只知道乔治·弗洛伊德生命最后阶段的一个极小的切片，就像录像里那样。然后你开始了解他作为一个人的整个人生，去思考他整个家族的历史以及这一切是如何通向这一刻的，这真的是很有力量的东西，对吧？这就好像在思考命运对某个人不公，这正是系统性种族主义的体现。是的，是的。
And Ashanti told me, you know, like these are facts, these aren't feelings. She's looking at the hard evidence behind these stories. Whereas my land is actually trying to create a database of land that was stolen by eminent domain and by other means. On their website, they have a page where black families can register their land
阿香提告诉我，你知道的，这些都是事实，而不是感觉。她正在寻找这些故事背后的铁证。而我的土地（Where Is My Land）实际上正试图建立一个数据库，收集通过行使征收权和其他手段被掠夺的土地。在他们的网站上，他们有一个页面，黑人家庭可以在上面登记他们的土地
and they've already gotten hundreds of claims. We have a case from Connecticut, California. A lot of cases are, of course, concentrated in the south, and they really span rural, urban, and suburban land. They go back to right around the time of land, they span, they go back to right around the time of reconstruction up through the 21st century. So that's really why we exist is to get at this from a national level and to just really wake people up as to the history specifically of the racially motivated theft of Black land. So where is my land is really trying to turn land reclamation into a movement? It has been so easy to ignore these families
而且他们已经收到了数百起索赔。我们有一个来自康涅狄格州、加利福尼亚州的案件。当然，许多案件都集中在南部，它们确实跨越了农村、城市和郊区土地。它们的历史可以追溯到重建时期前后，一直延续到21世纪。所以这正是我们存在的意义，从国家层面来处理这个问题，真正唤醒人们对特定历史的认识，特别是出于种族动机的黑人土地盗窃案。因此，“我的土地”确实在试图将土地收回变成一场运动。忽视这些家庭实在是太容易了
for so long because they haven't had anybody in their court fighting for them. So that's really what we want to change. I think we're going to be hearing more and more stories like Bruce's Beach and Venable Park. I mean, it's interesting because in the story that you reported, the Venable family didn't express interest in having the park and Creve Corps return to them as land, you know.
长期以来，因为他们身边没有任何人为他们伸张正义。所以这确实是我们想要改变的。我想我们将听到越来越多像布鲁斯海滩（Bruce's Beach）和维纳布尔公园（Venable Park）这样的故事。我的意思是，这很有趣，因为在你报道的故事中，维纳布尔家族并没有表达希望将公园和克雷ve科尔（Creve Coeur）作为土地归还给他们的意愿，你知道的。
Right. Yeah, so actually returning the land of the park to the Venable family, it hasn't really been part of the discussion so far. I think right now, the Venable family and the Creve Court Task Force are really focused on this memorial. They want to redesign the park and make it a destination, a place where people can go and learn about the history of the park and also of housing discrimination more broadly. And sort of talk about this from a national perspective. But I will say that much like Vanable Park was renamed recently, Bruce's
对。是的，所以实际上将公园的土地归还给维纳布尔家族，到目前为止还没有真正成为讨论的一部分。我认为现在，维纳布尔家族和克雷ve科尔工作组真的专注于这个纪念碑。他们想重新设计公园，使其成为一个目的地，一个人们可以去了解公园历史以及更广泛的住房歧视的地方。并从国家的角度来谈论这一点。但我必须说，就像维纳布尔公园最近被改名一样，布鲁斯的
Beach Park was renamed for the Bruce's in 2007. And you know, 14 years later, the land was returned. Wow. That's fascinating stuff. Well, thank you so much for sharing the story with us and this, this, this, I really appreciate it. Thank you, Roman. 99% of the visible was produced this week by Sophie Coddner, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales. Follini Hall is the executive producer, Kirk Colestetti, is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg,
海滩公园在2007年以布鲁斯家族的名字重新命名。你知道，14年后，土地被归还了。哇。太迷人了。好吧，非常感谢你与我们分享这个故事，这个，这个，我真的很感激。谢谢你，罗曼。本周的《99% Invisible》由索菲·科德纳制作，埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和技术制作。法利尼·霍尔是执行制作人，柯克·科莱斯蒂是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁比、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格、
Lashemadon, Jason De Leon, Sophia Klassger, and me Roman Mars. Music by a director of sound, Swan Rial, plus an additional song La Paresa by Duke Ellington and his Kentucky club orchestra. Special thanks this week to the Venable family, including Victoria Venable Fletcher and Crystal Venable, Sidney Jackson, Kimberly Norwood, Steve Stradaugh, Eric Berker, Mark and Nancy Codner, the office of the City of Creve Corps, the Missouri Historical Society, and the audio program at the UC Berkeley Cratchett School of Journalism. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious Exam Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north and the Pandora building.
拉舍马顿、杰森·德·莱昂、索菲亚·克拉斯格以及我罗曼·马尔斯。音乐由声音总监斯旺·里亚尔提供，此外还有杜克·艾灵顿及其肯塔基俱乐部乐团的额外歌曲《La Paresa》。本周特别感谢维纳布尔家族，包括维多利亚·维纳布尔·弗莱彻和水晶·维纳布尔、西德尼·杰克逊、金伯利·诺伍德、史蒂夫·斯特拉多、埃里克·伯克、马克和南茜·科德纳、克雷ve科尔市政府办公室、密苏里历史学会以及加州大学伯克利分校克拉切特新闻学院的音频节目。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。
And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Morris and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Stitcher. Serious. Excellent. Our limited series, The Future of, sponsored by the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, is all about exploring how changes to the way we live, learn, work, and play may shape our health
美丽的上城，加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，并在 @99PI org 上关注节目。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目。Stitcher. Sirius. Excellent. 我们的限定系列节目《The Future of》（由罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会赞助），全部关于探讨我们生活、学习、工作和娱乐方式的改变将如何塑造我们的健康
and well-being in years to come. Our second episode in the series, which we will release as a bonus episode of 99PI this week, is all about the future of broadband. A thing once viewed as a home luxury that is now a requirement for navigating the modern world. People without good internet access are at a severe disadvantage. Education, economic development and opportunity, which I'm relating to jobs, you are stricken from that. That is Monique Tate, a digital justice advocate. If you go somewhere and say, I'm interested in a job, can I just fill out a piece of paper,
以及未来的福祉。我们该系列的第二集，本周将作为 99PI 的特别福利单集发布，内容完全关于宽带的未来。曾经被视为家庭奢侈品的东西，现在成了驾驭现代世界的基本要求。没有良好互联网接入的人处于严重的劣势。教育、经济发展和机会——我将其与工作联系起来——你被剥夺了这些。这是数字正义倡导者莫妮克·泰特（Monique Tate）的话。如果你去某个地方说，我对工作感兴趣，我能填一张纸吗？
no one has that for you to do anymore. They're going to say, if you can't submit your application, we can't even consider you. On the next 99% invisible, we'll look at the past and future of broadband and the solutions people are coming up with to solve what's known as the last mile problem. This special episode is the second in a four-park series we created exploring the future of health and wellbeing. Each episode examines what we could do today to create a healthier, more equitable future.
没有人会让你这么做了。他们会说，如果你不能提交申请，我们甚至无法考虑你。在下一期的《99% Invisible》中，我们将探讨宽带的过去与未来，以及人们为解决被称为“最后一公里”问题而提出的解决方案。这个特别节目是我们制作的四部分系列节目的第二集，旨在探讨健康与福祉的未来。每一集都审视了我们今天可以做什么，以创造一个更健康、更公平的未来。
Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their sponsorship of the future of, to not miss a single episode, all you have to do is subscribe to 99% of us. Subscribe to 99% of visible. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会赞助《The Future of》，为了不错过任何一集，你只需订阅 99% Invisible。订阅 99% Invisible。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。